how does it feel to have number two
uh
basically
it's insane
i don't really know i mean i'm sort of
in the shot
what i have realized is my mum stole the
first one
oh she has it she has it so now
i have to keep this one away from my dad
otherwise i'm never going to ever
so i'm like this gives me another chance
but i gotta hide it i mean you got to
take something home to the fam right go
take something out yeah they can share
it
what does it mean that this show i mean
that people universally love and you're
up in a category against so many of your
co-workers it was crazy that category
well i don't i mean i get it because
we've all got lives to live but i wish
you could do a five-minute speech so
that you could really talk about the
other nominee like what can list what
did you want to say what would you have
wanted to say that you didn't get to say
like
all of that list uh
i felt
it since all of it's insane but to be
even in the same list as like henry
winkler and anthony carrigan who were
so good they were so good
and tyler from abbott elementary so good
i mean
it was like a a series of legends like
it's in
i felt like i don't really i shouldn't
really i felt like you know you think
i shouldn't really be on this list
you're like i don't belong here yeah
yeah yeah that's a heck of a list and to
even nick
uh the bet i don't know it's it's a very
silly it's very silly in it
do you find that you say
a lot more now that since you
can less because of the
i think i always i don't you could tell
the difference before
does it do you say it more because of
that because of roy cat yeah you say it
more if that's my legacy i'm very proud
the legacy
yeah dropping f-bombs throughout the
world inspiring youngsters hey um how's
this how's the season going you're
shooting it right now we're shooting in
london uh we are
how close are we i think we're
pretty close to the end and i think
we're all is this the end is this the
end oh boy
this question
uh i
i don't know it's all in jason's hands
you have to ask jason that in in we've
been writing it like it's the end
but i know we would all love to do it
forever and i i
think so you've been writing the show
like this is it yeah it's an ending i
mean three people die in the end
no come on no i shouldn't
not through not all of them are like
beloved
you're messing with it because i love
that you're messing with but you're
about the two of the two of them where
they're like you know people you didn't
like it two of them died and they rarely
mentioned it and then one of them is a
huge huge loss to the show but it's the
end so it doesn't matter
anyway enjoy look forward to it
he's messing with it don't believe that
don't believe that but it is it could be
the end could be the end
but i don't know
it's really not for me to say okay so
when you go back out to the table and
you sit down do you take the emmy out
there and and you just put in the table
and you got um your other two co-stars
looking at you what do you say what do
you say to them i haven't thought this
through you haven't thought about that
you're going back i'm not going back i'm
just gonna get on a
you're leaving yeah they'll never see me
again they will never see me again
real quick um will you guys pause
shooting or anything because of all the
stuff going on with the queen
i think there's that we have one day off
for the funeral oh you will take next
monday off for the funeral yeah how's
that been what has it been like being in
the uk during that time i think uh
it's very strange because everything
everything stopped everything stopped
yeah and uh
and people just feel that fill the
streets it's pretty strange it's a
stranger i think she's always been
around she's always been around she's
been around you know yeah all our
parents all uh
most of our anyone who's got
grandparents is still younger than the
queen you know what i mean she was there
yeah it's hard to imagine now you have
king charles iii yeah weird weird right
wait what man congratulations how's the
party gonna be i heard you guys gonna
have the crazy turn-up party tonight i
i'm not allowed to divulge any
information about the party i imagine
there'll be some tea
a little tea a little bit see
little bits here maybe
i have no idea i actually have no idea
by the way do they have alcohol at the
tables there's a bottle of wine but it
was gone already it's gone it's gone to
all the other people on the table
they've had a lot